c'est la destination
non pas le droit de faire ça
c'est fou quand même alors voilà alors
c'était cette tenue exactement vous
sortiez de soirée
donc forcément vous êtes dit on va se
terminer la soirée quoi en fait oui on
veut aller manger un petit déj vous
saviez que vous allez vous faire vocal
ou pas bah pas du tout parce que c'est
un bistrot je suis allé plusieurs fois
j'y allais en jogging en mode
décolleté et il y avait quelqu'un
je vous dis la vérité moi je ne
comprends pas je comprends pas la
décision du gars sans déconner mais
c'est quoi c'est non vous avez une
embrouille avec lui rien du tout en fait
là on criait tout mais de base on est
rentré on était très poli
il était quelle heure aujourd'hui 8h du
matin c'est ça ouais bon mais je vous
dis franchement je comprends pas moi en
fait je sais pas mon ami avec quelque
chose contre vous je sais pas parce que
le matin j'arrive pas à comprendre quoi
alors ce c'est le matin en fait moi j'ai
eu le géant du restaurant en fait il est
8h du matin il dit qu'il y a des
familles qui prennent des petits
déjeuners que ça a pu choquer des
familles moi je moi franchement je
comprends enfin tes familles qui
prennent des petits déjeuner
une partie de la clientèle et moi
au-delà de ça enfin les tenues et c'est
vrai qu'il y a un des ballets dessus
mais moi c'est tout ce que je déteste
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est-à-dire que
voilà vous arrivez vous vous mettez à
crier vous filmez la scène en hurlant à
la discrimination tout ça pour gagner 3
abonnés sur Tik Tok je suis désolé moi
personnellement j'ai rien contre vous
mais je trouve ça concernant
[Applaudissements]
c'est la police du costume teinté de
misogynie c'est de la discrimination
vous citiez qui les Noirs oui ils sont
refoulés et elles sont refoulées parce
qu'elles sont des femmes
c'est de la misogynie pure et simple
c'est de la misogynie Daniel avec la
même tenue
c'est parfaitement hors-la-loi il n'a
pas le droit j'étais dans des tenues
décentes elle voulait prendre un petit
déjeuner on les refoule
il a été très je suis désolé alors vous
c'est vrai que voilà
Toutatice mais là Paul Seka je suis
désolé la tenue elle est je pourrais la
mettre
de face
car quand vous entendez ça vous dites
c'est ça continue la discrimination que
vous savez pas ce que le monsieur a déjà
avant quand il nous a dit il a commencé
à donner déjà des des excuses et après
qu'on nous a dit non mais dites-nous
clairement pourquoi vous le refusez il a
dit vous avez des tenues de
stripteaseuses oui vous décolleté c'est
n'importe quoi on dirait des prostituées
ça veut dire que vous cautionnez des
propos ça veut dire non mais moi c'est
pas la réaction en fait c'est vous savez
qu'en disant la tenue a arrêté de face
ça va arrêter non là je suis pas
d'accord avec vous là là sur la tenue de
de polka là la tenue Guillaume la tenue
là bah moi je comprends la réaction
après il peut y avoir un débat là-dessus
mais accusé par la tenue voilà sur la
tenue je parle pas très le problème
c'est crier si ça m'était deux mecs qui
seraient arrivés habillé torse
et le problème c'est pas tant ça c'est
le fait de crier au scandale pour un oui
ou pour un nom et parce que le patron du
restaurant le résultat c'est qu'il se
fait insulter aujourd'hui toute la
journée et qui a d'autres restaurants si
si au téléphone il se fiche et il y a
des restaurants elles sont insultés il y
a des restaurants non mais je cautionne
pas non plus mais il y a des restaurants
malheureusement il y a vraiment du
racisme où il y a vraiment de
l'homophobie il y a vraiment de la
discrimination et il faut arrêter
aujourd'hui de crier au scandale pour
tout et n'importe quoi tout ce que vous
voulez faire c'est faire du buzz à deux
balles
bien sûr que oui
j'aimerais bien voir la vie à la vie de
de de de tout le monde est victime
d'agressions Béatrice toi tu es choqué
ou pas le le gérant ou le propriétaire a
dit que si elles étaient venus le soir
il les auraient laisser rentrer c'est
bien ce qu'elle a dit on l'a entendu
pendant la vidéo donc vraiment ce qu'il
dérangeait c'était le matin et le fait
que ce soit pas le public adéquat avec
des tenues comme ça
ça donne ton avis un peu porte tes
couilles excuse-moi
excuse-moi Gilles
on peut pas devenir la police de la de
de des vêtements et après le décolleté
va être de plus en plus petit et tout va
choquer donc ça je suis d'accord mais là
c'est vraiment abusé
le matin dans avec un public familial
oui ou non dans le contexte oui Delphine
est-ce qu'on peut remettre la tenue rose
oui est-ce qu'on peut remettre la tenue
rose non mais la tenue rose alors au
mois de juillet ça passe au mois de
novembre c'est différent
en en tout cas je pense qu'un
restaurateur ne peut pas interdire en
fonction d'une tenue donc oui oui c'est
la prestation de chacun mais je suis
désolé tu peux te faire refoul quand tu
vas en boîte parce qu'il y a un dress
code mais dans les lieux publics et dans
les restaurants et dans la rue il y a
pas de dress code donc si les filles
veulent s'habiller un peu plus court
parce qu'il fait chaud et elles ont le
droit quoi tu es d'accord avec podcast
et et si j'aime le mettre pas je crois
que le premier bouton était ouvert il me
semble de votre truc rose excuse-moi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une affaire commerciale moi je les
accepte bien sûr que c'est pas évident
mais je les accepte c'est bon tu vas pas
les accepter parce que nous on est quand
même je te le dis non mais tu les
accepte pas parce qu'on est de
l'extérieur il faut savoir où elles ont
été c'est une brasserie ou c'est qu'il y
a du bordel le soir c'est à Bastille il
y a des fois il y a du bordel et des
fois quand Harry tu vois deux personnes
arrivées comme ça je te dis peut-être
que elles ont bu toute la nuit peut-être
qu'elles vont me [ __ ] le bordel avec
les gens qui prennent leur petit
déjeuner et peut-être que moi en tant
que patron de bistrot peut-être que
j'aurais dit vous ne rentrez pas parce
que là là c'est pas la bonne heure en
fait venez à 23 minuit on boit des
bières ensemble et là c'est pas la bonne
heure et tous les bistrots qui sont dans
ce quartier là qui est ce quartier chaud
de Bastille ils ont affaire à des trucs
comme ça et souvent ils refont
dit la loi là-dessus à 20h38 on dirait
que je vous le dis un restaurateur
peut-il refuser d'accueillir des clients
la loi n'est pas très précise sur les
camps en question mais la réponse est
globalement non il n'a pas le droit le
restaurateur peut refuser un client dans
certaines circonstances si celui-ci
semble agressif ou dangereux dans son
comportement s'il est ivre mais
également si l'âge aussi une tenue
inappropriée
c'est si tu arrives le zizi à l'air hein
si par exemple elle avait beaucoup moins
de 100 ils auraient rien dire ah oui bah
oui si par exemple elle aurait beaucoup
moins de 100 et ça aurait peut-être pas
choqué mais elle est comme ça elle est
comme ça parce que là
même sa tenue même sa tenue à toi je
pense qu'elle choque aussi tu t'en rends
pas compte mais je pense que à 7h30 du
matin tu te dis c'est une sortie de
boîte oui mais tu vois ce que toi tu
vois à 23h minuit ça me dérange pas à
23h00
dans mon bar est-ce qu'elles vont [ __ ]
le bordel est-ce que vous criez comment
je les sors une fois que je les ai fait
rentrer comment je les sors moi je livre
des restaurants j'ai plein de
restaurants les mecs qui me disent moi
je laisse pas rentrer ça je laisse pas
rentrer j'étais pas le droit il me dit
je suis chez moi alors chez moi
c'est pas bien
tu as été triste
ou quoi
pour un café non en fait je m'en fous
quoi tu t'en fous en fait
tu t'en fous je m'en fous pas la raison
vraiment on se recale on a fait du bruit
maintenant je m'en fous on a fait du
bruit
tu as envie de dire quoi
déjà je m'en fous en fait
je m'en fous des critiques je m'en fous
des je m'en fous quoi
[Rires]
tu t'en fous moi
je m'en fous mais quand même ça m'énerve
un petit peu
on dirait le matin on peut pas
s'habiller comme des tchoin le soir oui
enfin je sais pas
quand on juge une tenue trop sexy on est
forcément misogyne non je suis désolé et
moi je regrette presque ça pour vous en
fait je pense que c'est votre métier
entre guillemets de tik Tokyo ce qui
vous a poussé à devenir comme ça parce
qu'on sait je sais pas tic-tocause non
mais influenceuse
c'est ça qui pousse à ça parce qu'en
fait vous êtes tellement dans une
enquête de validation de like de vue on
sait que la nudités
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en fait c'est que la nudité voilà c'est
suicide de l'intérêt ça vous rend sexy
ça vous rend attractive et voilà c'est
vrai que c'est tenues elles peuvent
choquer des gens ils peuvent choquer sur
les réseaux sociaux quand c'est des
enfants qui voient vos vidéos et elles
peuvent choquer dans un café le matin
quand il y a des familles qui viennent
prendre un petit déjeuner et qui n'ont
peut-être vous pas envie de voir des
filles qui sont hyper sexualisées et ça
ne fait pas de ces gens-là des gens
misogyne ni du gérant de ce café c'est
tout venez nous votre avis chez vous il
est 20h41 on est en direct du Géraldine
alors pour moi vous aviez exactement
comme vous voulez tout me va en revanche
moi je crois pas à votre sincérité je
pense qu'en fait vous avez remis une
sorte de pièces dans votre jukebox de
pseudo notoriété et en fait ça vous
arrange bien ce besoin rabais en fait
pour moi ça me fait penser à ce fameux
twerker dans l'église alors évidemment
c'est moins grave mais en fait si vous
aviez été accepté dans le restaurant en
fait je pense que vous auriez moins aimé
que parce que vous avez été recalé
maintenant d'être calé ça permet d'en
parler de médiatiser de venir sur un
plateau télé et ça crée une spirale de
médiatisation c'est notre ami qui est
sur la photo donc ouais mais donc vous
saviez qu'il allait avoir un truc ou pas
pour que vous rentrez pour avoir des
preuves quoi
[Musique]
on va filmer comme ça
il était plus cordial mais là vous
arrivez
première fois vous étiez déjà fait
recaler une première fois à l'écart moi
c'est la première fois que ça m'arrive
du coup bah j'étais choqué je me suis je
peux pas laisser passer
oui Delphine
oui oui non le le la personne qui a
filmé vous avez
pardon excuse-moi de t'avoir dérangé
une première fois et c'est pour ça que
ensuite pour la vidéo on voit la
personne filmée de loin c'est à dire
vous êtes fait recaler vous êtes parti
vous avez pris de l'élan et puis vous
êtes revenu en filmant c'est ça le truc
en fait ouais genre vous êtes vraiment
éloigné puis vous êtes revenu tous les
gens qui vous critiquent sur les sur les
réseaux ça vous touche ou pas
c'est leur business aussi ça participe à
leur business c'est la notoriété
monétiser c'est tout ça elles ont pas
besoin de nous hein
d'avoir filmé le fait d'avoir été viré
c'est-à-dire que vous retournez le truc
heureusement qu'elles ont filmé que
toutes les discriminations dans les
restaurants si elles ne sont pas filmées
il y a pas de preuve ça ne marche pas
donc là vous avez la preuve que deux
jeunes femmes ont été discriminées et
Raymond peu importe l'heure le matin le
soir et vous trouvez ça quasiment normal
moi je suis révolté d'entendre ça sur le
plateau
franchement je comprends pas ça vous
vient pas à l'esprit que on on va pas
dans un restaurant avec des pantoufles
avec un décolleté gigantesque mais
comment tu fais pour pour manger des
œufs brouillés
il faut faire deux minutes là où vous
faites de vous faites les uns pour avoir
du son mais honnêtement c'est évident
mais c'est évident mademoiselle que on
va on va pas dans un restaurant
Halloween en ninja voilà c'est
excusez-moi il y a rien ça vous vient
pas attendez non mais d'accord mais il
est 8h du matin dans un restaurant il y
a plein de restaurant qui oblige les
mecs à mettre une cravate et une veste
et une personne
comment je sais pas où tu vas je vais
demander excusez-moi vous rentrez pas
dans un grand hôtel cinq étoiles
maintenant si maintenant c'est fini
maintenant c'est fini ça c'est pas vrai
casino short maintenant dis pas de
bêtises
qui vont au casino ont perdu la je te le
dis quand on s'appelle
franchement il a discrimination les
montants tenue correctes exigées où est
le problème
il y a pas de scandale il a pas envie
d'avoir des nanas qui sont à moitié dans
son restaurant et ben il a bien raison
de le dire et de le faire après elle
revienne elles se font filmer c'est du
buzz effectivement à deux balles et il y
a 0 scandale il y a des devoir du mal
partout vous vous êtes vraiment à côté
de la plaque définitivement comme
toujours voilà
[Applaudissements]
simplement que moi j'ai une fille vous
avez 4 garçons déjà
les réseaux sociaux vous avez des fils
qui s'exhibent sur les réseaux sociaux
qui ont envie et vous critiquez dans une
jeune femme qui vit des réseaux sociaux
[Applaudissements]
de s'habiller librement le seul refus
que l'on peut le reposer c'est de
l'exhibition sexuelle
j'aimerais j'aimerais le mot de la fin
de Paul Skype Toutatice alors Toutatice
je m'en fous
[Rires]
qui parle je m'en fous je vais pas
arrêter de sortir comme ça
ils disent quoi tes parents
si ça rapporte de l'argent c'est bien
sinon
ma mère avant elle était
dubitative mais après quand on l'a vu
pareil que je peux offrir des beaux
cadeaux des voyages
là comme ça bah oui après
moi j'ai 19 ans j'étais comme ça depuis
16 ans
en fait et moi je trouve que ce
restaurateur est très poli il vous
explique que c'est parce que c'est le
matin qui vous accueillerez le soir je
trouve qu'il faut mettre des limites
dans la vie je pense que vous n'êtes pas
dans la dans la réalité et surtout ne
vous ne pensez pas que c'est un combat
féministe il y a très peu de femmes qui
se retrouvent en vous donc il y a des
vrais combats féministes et celui-ci
n'en est pas un je suis désolé et si
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
toi tu t'en fous toi
sur les réseaux je m'en fous de comment
les gens ils vont au restaurant je m'en
fous dit qu'aurait son quel religion je
m'en fous
dans le restaurant c'était le mais pas
moi évidemment regardez la victoire mais
c'est le petit-déjeuner voilà c'est le
petit déjeuner
ou quoi
arrêtez avec ce petit déjeuner c'est
énorme
MERCI non mais merci c'est bon j'ai
rallye je vous remercie Paul SCA merci
d'avoir été là merci peut-être
c'est Gilles qui a fait ça sonne merci
en tout cas d'avoir été là
[Applaudissements]